in this everchanging world being a
business analyst is a crucial job these
professionals help companies reach their
goals by understanding what's needed you
need more than just data skills to do
this job well in 2024 in this video we
will explore the top 10 skills that are
important for business analysis these
skills help business analysts come up
with new ideas solve tricky problems and
Lead their companies towards success but
before we begin let me ask you a quick
question so what is the primary goal of
a business
analyst option A is increase company
profits option b is solve technical
issues option C is improve business
processes and option D is enhance
employee satisfaction now you can pause
this video and answer in the comment
section below meanwhile let's start with
the first topic which is who is a
business analyst so a business analyst
plays a crucial role in driving
organizational change by understanding
and addressing businesses challenges and
offering solutions that optimize value
for stakeholders they are involved in
all aspects of the business from
strategic planning to developing
Enterprise architecture a business
analyst tool extends Beyond just problem
solving they are enrolled in every tiny
aspect of the business from Gathering
requirements and conducting feasibility
studies to facilitating communication
between different teams they act as a
bridge between stakeholders that is
business stakeholders and Technical
teams ensuring that everyone is on the
same page and working towards a common
goal so this was about who is a business
analyst now let's have a look at the
business analysis skills so let's start
with the first one which is business
intelligence tools so business
intelligence tools like sap business
objects IBM cognos and Microsoft powerbi
are essential for business analysts
these tool enable analysts to create
reports dashboard and interactive
visualizations providing valuable
insights to stakeholders bi tools
consolidate data from multiple sources
revealing patterns and correlations that
may go unnoticed with Advanced Data
visualization capabilities analyst can
present complex information in a
visually appealing and interactive
format additionally self-service
features Empower analysts to access and
analyze data independently enhancing
agility and responsiveness familiarity
with these bi tools is crucial for anal
lists to leverage data effectively and
drive business success next skill on the
list is
research research skills are essential
for business analyst as they form the
foundation for finding solutions to
company problems it involves Gathering
relevant information and statistical
data necessary for developing Solutions
business analyst must utilize their it
and technological skills to collect
accurate data and analyze it regularly
they are responsible for providing high
quality and detailed requirements to all
project stakeholders ensuring that their
research can address any questions or
concerns that may arise by conducting
thoro research business analyst can make
informed decisions and contribute to the
success of projects by providing
valuable insights and recommendations
all right coming to the next one which
is data review and statistical analysis
data review and statistical analysis are
critical skills for business analy data
review involves examining and accessing
data sets quality complete nness and
accuracy business analyst must have the
ability to identify any inconsistencies
or erors in the data and ensure its
reliability statistical analysis is the
process of applying statistical
techniques to data in order to uncover
patterns relationships and Trends
business analyst use statistical
analysis to gain insights and make data
driven decisions they employ various
statistical methods such as regression
analysis hypothesis testing and data
modeling to extract meaningful
information from the data by conducting
thoro data review business analyst can
uncover valuable insights identify
patrons and make informed
recommendations to stakeholders these
skills enable them to provide accurate
and reliable information that support
effective decision making and drives
business success also if you are
interested in taking your career to the
next level look no further our business
analyst Masters program is your gateway
to becoming a job ready with globally
recognized certification we cover all
three vital aspects of business analysis
planning and monitoring requirements
elicitation requirements management and
communication Etc gets hands-on
experience with the latest tools work on
real world projects and gain invaluable
insights through exclusive master
classes led by IBM experts don't
hesitate seize the opportunity to shape
your future enroll now and embark on a
transformative Journey towards a
successful career in business analysis
finishing the course led to personal
recognition and open the door for even
more artificial intelligent projects and
it came with a significant pay raise my
had hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years old and
last year I upskill with simp
postgraduate program in cyber security
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exam on the first attempt
after taking the course we decided to
take a course in devops from Simply
learn the course proved to be very
beneficial for both our careers yeah I
got a promotion after the course and I
got to hire with a new company I first I
try to learn from YouTube and then apply
for new job but I wouldn't corre then
one of my friends suggested I go for a
certification post with simp My overall
experience with simply was very good
within a few days I went three calls two
our project management positions and one
was in data science I successfully
change my career from software
development to digital marketing and
simply learn presented the perfect route
I chose simply learn because of its
tremendously High weighting to be r as
one of the best Education portal online
worldwide is surely promising I switched
to a new role as a digital marketing
manager with this my skill upgraded my
salary increased and my self-confident
Boost alongside numerous other positive
outcomes all right next one is process
modeling and Analysis so process
modeling and Analysis are vital skills
for business analysts they involve using
techniques like bpmn and tools such as
Aris or visual to map and analyze
business processes by visually
representing process and identify
inefficiencies analyst can propose
improvements these skills enable analyst
to simulate scenarios making performance
and identify bottlenecks or areas of low
efficiency through process modeling and
Analysis analysts can optimize process
reduce cost and enhance customer
satisfaction next on the list is
knowledge of Erp and CRM
systems having knowledge of Enterprise
resources planning Erp systems such as
sap or Oracle as well as customer
relationship management I repeat like
Salesforce is highly beneficial for
business
analysts these systems are crucial in
managing and streamlining various
aspects of a business Erp systems are
designed to integrate and manage Core
Business processes including Finance
human resource Supply Chain management
and Manufacturing understanding Erp
systems allow business analysts to
gather requirements effectively evaluate
the integration needs and support
implementation projects CRM systems
focus on on managing customer
interactions and relationships they
provide a centralized platform for
storing customer Data Tracking sales
activities and managing marketing
campaigns familiarity with CRM systems
enable business analyst to assess the
customer needs identify opportunities
for enhancing customer experience all
right coming to the next skill which is
creation of reports and dashboards
creating reports and dashboards is a
crucial skill for business analysts they
need to be proficient in business
intellig tools like table click View and
powerbi to develop General and dashboard
reports these reports help in solving
decision making Problems by providing
valuable insights business analysts
should have a profound understanding of
these tools by leveraging their
knowledge of these tools analysts can
effectively present data in a visually
appealing and easily understandable
manner enabling stakeholders to make
informed
decisions next skill on the list is
Microsoft
Excel next Microsoft Exel as we all know
it is a very important skill this is a
fundamental skill that every business
analyst must have Excel is one of the
oldest and strongest analytical and
Reporting tools business analyst can use
it perform several calculations data and
budget analysis to unrel business
pattern they summarize data by creating
pivot tables they make different charts
using Excel to generate Dynamic reports
related to business problem business
analyst use Excel to calculate customer
discounts
based on monthly purchase volume by
product they even summarize customer
Revenue by product to find areas where
there is a need to build stronger
customer relationships all these things
tell us like how important is Excel for
business analysis all right coming to
the next one which is documentation and
presentation documentation and
presentation are crucial skills for
business analyst effective documentation
involves recording project insights and
outcomes in a very clear and concise
manner this allows for easy reference
and knowledge transfer additionally
business analysts must confidently
present their findings to stakeholders
and clients by delivering well
structured presentations they can
effectively communicate project outcomes
and recommendations furthermore
organized documentation enables business
analyst to bridge the gap between
Technical and non-technical employees
facilitating the understanding of
complex Concepts mastering documentation
and presentation skills enhance a
business analyst's ability to convey
information and contribute to successful
project implementation so so this is
another important skill coming to the
next one which is requirement management
requirement management is a crucial
aspect of project development it
involves utilizing tools such as jira
Confluence or IBM rational doors to
proficiently handle requirements these
tools Aid business analyst in capturing
documentation tracking and managing
requirements throughout the Project Life
Cycle by leveraging these tools teams
can ensure that all necessary
requirements are identified documented
and effectively communicated this
streamlined approach enhances
collaborations minimizes errors and
facilitates efficient project execution
so this was about the top 10 business
analysis skills for
2024 and that's all for today's video so
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up I hope it really help you all
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills
or a working professional looking to
advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here